You might have guessed that the perimeter is the distance around an object. So
if I just add up the distances around an object, I can find the perimeter. For
this one, I have 2 d's and, and 2 3's, so the perimeter is 2d plus 6. The d's
have the same length, so we can add them together. They're like terms. The
perimeter of this shape is 2a plus 3b. We don't know the length of these two
sides, but we can add them together because they're both a, they have the same
length. The same is true for the b's. Be careful that you don't write 5ab here.
We can't combine these two terms. a is one number, and b is another number. I'm
not multiplying, I'm really adding the distances around the object. If you got
these two right, nice work.